I'd like to thank my new shark tank  partners Brian and Eric from prx  performers on a job well done now get to  work and make me some money  I'd also like to help Brian and Eric  bring attention to another team of  entrepreneurs out of Fargo North Dakota  like many entrepreneurs they quit their  job to follow a passion but this passion  wasn't about money it was about  eradicating global human trafficking  unseen is a Fargo based nonprofit that  partners with existing groups who are  already successfully fighting human  trafficking on scene equips these  organizations with the storytelling  media and marketing tools to accelerate  their programming and rescue more  children finally unseen trains and  educates their partners on how to grow  and invite others to fight together  against human trafficking all from  downtown Fargo if you'd like to support  this worthy cause go to we are unseen  org and thank you for listening